Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The Germans are a good people. On the whole, the best people perhaps in the world. An amiable, unselfish, kindly people. I'm positive that the vast majority of them go to heaven. Indeed, comparing them with the other Christian nations of the earth, one is forced to the conclusion that heaven will be chiefly of German manufacture.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、享受无广告体验、抢先收听系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。德国人是一个优秀的民族。总的来说，或许是世界上最优秀的民族。他们和蔼、无私、善良。我确信他们中的绝大多数人都会升入天堂。事实上，将他们与其他基督教国家相比，人们不得不得出结论：天堂将主要由德国制造。
Now that was the comic writer Jerome K. Jerome in his book Three Men on a Bummel, published in 1900. And I'll try to remember those words when, in this week's titanic footballing clash between our two great nations, the last German penalty screams into the net and it is heartbreak for England yet again. Tom, Tom Holland, it is just as well, isn't it, that the Germans don't play cricket. Imagine that. Well, actually, Dominic, they do. Yeah, they do. Probably the most humiliating moment in last year's lamentable performance on the COVID front in England was when Germans came out of lockdown before we did. And as a result, they were playing cricket when it was banned in England.
那是喜剧作家杰罗姆·K·杰罗姆在 1900 年出版的《三人同舟》（Three Men on a Bummel）一书中所写的话。在本周我们两个伟大国家之间那场泰坦尼克号般的足球对决中，当德国队的最后一粒点球呼啸着钻入网窝，英格兰再次心碎时，我会试着记住这些话。汤姆，汤姆·霍兰德，幸好德国人不玩板球，对吧？想象一下。嗯，其实，多米尼克，他们玩。是的，他们玩。去年英格兰在新冠疫情应对方面表现糟糕，最丢脸的时刻可能就是德国人比我们先解封的时候。结果，当板球在英格兰被禁止时，他们却在打板球。
So I think that's the only time probably in history that cricket's been legal in Germany and banned in England. And that's a bad moment, isn't it? It was a terrible moment. I still haven't read it. It's probably the end of days. Yeah, that's what it felt like. I mean, that's when it really hit me.
所以我认为这可能是历史上唯一一次板球在德国合法而但在英格兰被禁止。那是一个糟糕的时刻，不是吗？那是一个可怕的时刻。我还没读过那段。那可能是世界末日。是的，感觉就是那样。我的意思是，那是我真正受到冲击的时候。
Have we ever, obviously, we've played Germany multiple times in different arenas. Have we ever played them at cricket? I don't think we have, but it's obviously a matter of time. Yeah. They're clearly plotting their path to greatness. Imagine that moment when they win at Lords or something. I know, I know, on penalties.
我们有没有，显然，我们在不同的赛场上多次与德国交手。我们有没有在板球比赛中与他们交过手？我想我们没有，但这显然只是时间问题。是的。他们显然正在策划通往伟大的道路。想象一下他们在板球总部（Lords）或其他什么地方获胜的那一刻。我知道，我知道，通过点球大战。
I'm sure they'll find a way to do it. Yeah, in a super over. That's exactly what it will be. That's exactly what it will be. All of which I'm aware will be total gibberish, perhaps, to people who have no interest in football or cricket or anything. But essentially, Dominic, as you say, the reason for the theme of this podcast, which is Anglo-German relations, is that yet again, England have been drawn against germany in a huge international tournament um yeah and we know how it's going to end but before england lose let's let's let's look at the whole theme of anglo-german relations which of course um is is
我相信他们会找到办法做到的。是的，在超级轮（super over）中。那正是会发生的事情。那正是会发生的事情。我知道，对于那些对足球、板球或其他任何东西不感兴趣的人来说，这一切可能都是胡言乱语。但本质上，多米尼克，正如你所说，本期播客的主题——英德关系——的原因是，英格兰又一次在大型国际赛事中抽到了德国，嗯，是的，我们知道结果会怎样。但在英格兰输球之前，让我们来看看英德关系的整个主题，当然，嗯，这是
founded if you follow the opinion of the terraces uh on the idea that England have won two World Wars and one World Cup, ignoring the fact... How many World Cups have the Germans won? Four. The four we've won in 1966, one of the tabloids, I think it was the Mirror, I might be wrong, said, if England lose on Saturday, we should remember that they may have beaten us once
建立在看台上的观点之上，即英格兰赢得了两次世界大战和一次世界杯，忽略了事实……德国人赢得了多少次世界杯？四次。我们在 1966 年赢得的那一次，我想是《镜报》吧，也许我记错了，说如果英格兰周六输了，我们应该记住，他们可能在我们的国民运动中击败过我们一次，
at our national sport, but we've beaten them twice at theirs, which is the sort of commentary that now is frowned upon yes but in the 1960s was regarded as very jolly badinage well i mean obviously we we do tend to um see anglo-german relations through the prism of the two world wars yeah i mean that's you know we've just recorded a two-part episode with um in kershaw and Hitler so that obviously does very much kind of dominate perspective but I think it it clouds the degree to which actually over the course of the centuries and indeed the millennia relations between the English and the Germans have been closer well there's an argument isn't there that the English are the Germans I mean some people
但我们在他们的国民运动中击败过他们两次，这种评论现在是不被赞许的，是的，但在 20 世纪 60 年代被认为是十分愉快的调侃。嗯，我的意思是，显然我们确实倾向于通过两次世界大战的棱镜来看待英德关系，是的，我的意思是，你知道，我们刚刚录制了一个关于伊恩·克肖和希特勒的两部分剧集，所以这显然在很大程度上主导了视角，但我认为这掩盖了这样一个事实：实际上，几个世纪甚至几千年来，英国人和德国人之间的关系一直很亲密。嗯，有一种观点，不是吗，英国人就是德国人？我的意思是，有些人
Victorians kind of thought that didn't they well in that the English are the Germans? I mean, some become England. And that sense of kinship, whether it's true or not, whether it's a myth or whether it's rooted in historical fact, is certainly one that the Angles and the Saxons themselves believed. They had a very strong sense of kinship. And that's why the great apostle of the Germans, the man who is credited by the Germans themselves converting them to Christianity, is a man from Devon, St. Boniface. That's interesting. So he was the sort of man who would be drawn
维多利亚时代的人确实是这么想的，不是吗？嗯，英国人就是德国人？我的意思是，有些人变成了英格兰人。那种亲缘感，无论它是真是假，是神话还是植根于历史事实，无疑是盎格鲁人和撒克逊人自己所相信的。他们有非常强烈的亲缘感。这就是为什么德国人的伟大使徒，被德国人自己认为是将他们皈依基督教的人，是一个来自德文郡的人，圣博尼法斯。这很有趣。所以他就是那种会被卷入
into one of those abstruse arguments about scones with the Cornish. I imagine that's why he left. I imagine that's why he left I imagine that's why he left he left Wessex behind and went off to uh to convert the uh the Saxons of course who were pagan at the time and it's interesting because what the reason that the um the Pope wants to convert the English why he sends the missionaries with you know Augustine to Canterbury is because he sees Britain as having originally been part of the Roman Empire. And therefore, because they were Romans, therefore, they should probably be Christian. He's not
与康沃尔人关于司康饼的深奥争论中的人。我想这就是他离开的原因。我想这就是他离开的原因，我想这就是他离开的原因，他把威塞克斯抛在身后，去皈依了当时还是异教徒的撒克逊人。当然，这很有趣，因为教皇想要皈依英国人的原因，他派遣传教士（比如奥古斯丁）去坎特伯雷，是因为他认为英国最初是罗马帝国的一部分。因此，因为他们是罗马人，所以他们可能应该成为基督徒。他并不
really interested in people beyond the limits of what had been the Roman Empire. But the Angles and the Saxons aren't bound by that. They feel a strong sense of kinship with their pagan cousins across the waters. And so that's why they cross the sea, um they go into the kind of the dank dripping forests of saxony yeah to tremendous effect and um boniface ends up being um martyred in frisia and his body is then taken to fulda um where it becomes a massive center of pilgrimage and so to this day he's the patron saint i think of europe of of Germany and of Devon, which is quite a record. That is a record, the big three. Yeah, absolutely.
真正关心罗马帝国边界以外的人。但盎格鲁人和撒克逊人不受此限制。他们对海对岸的异教徒表亲有着强烈的亲缘感。所以这就是他们跨海的原因，嗯，他们进入了萨克森那种潮湿滴水的森林，是的，效果惊人，嗯，博尼法斯最终在弗里斯兰殉道，他的遗体随后被带到富尔达，那里成为了一个巨大的朝圣中心，所以直到今天，他仍然是欧洲、德国和德文郡的守护神，这真是一个了不起的记录。那确实是一个记录，三大圣地。是的，绝对是。
So I think that as England and Germany take the field at Wembley, we should keep St. Boniface in mind. I think we should. Because he's something that we all share in common. But isn't the weird thing, though, Tom, I was thinking about this, that for much of our medieval history, I for one thing germany isn't germany right i mean germany is is the empire and it's this patchwork of territories as it remains until the 19th century but also england is so sort of orientated towards france that germany doesn't really seem to feature as much as you know you can sort of read a book about england in the middle ages and germany, apart from sort of Hanseatic traders or something, Germany barely seems to feature
所以我认为，当英格兰和德国在温布利球场上场时，我们应该记住圣博尼法斯。我认为我们应该。因为他是我们共同拥有的东西。但奇怪的是，汤姆，我一直在想，在我们中世纪历史的大部分时间里，我首先认为德国不是德国，对吧？我的意思是，德国是帝国，它是一个领土拼凑体，直到 19 世纪依然如此，但英格兰也如此倾向于法国，以至于德国似乎并没有像你所知道的那样占据重要地位，你可以读一本关于中世纪英格兰的书，除了汉萨同盟的商人或其他什么人之外，德国几乎没有出现过
at all. It's all about France, isn't it? Yeah. And in terms of kind of national rivalries, obviously England's traditional enemy is France. Yes. But it's interesting that that doesn't translate into football. No, but partly because the French weren't very good at football until relatively recently.
一点。全都是关于法国的，不是吗？是的。就民族竞争而言，显然英格兰的传统敌人是法国。是的。但有趣的是，这并没有转化为足球。不，但这部分是因为法国人在相对较近的时间之前足球踢得并不好。
But they are now, aren't they? They're going to win. They are good, but I don't think football has... I mean, this is a whole different subject, but I don't think football is as deeply embedded in French culture as it is in some of its neighbours' culture. I mean, they care about cycling and stuff. But, I mean, it's interesting that Ich dien, I serve, which is the motto of the Prince of Wales.
但他们现在很厉害，不是吗？他们会赢的。他们很厉害，但我认为足球并没有……我的意思是，这是一个完全不同的主题，但我认为足球在法国文化中并不像在它的一些邻国文化中那样根深蒂固。我的意思是，他们关心自行车运动之类的。但是，我的意思是，有趣的是“Ich dien”（我服务），这是威尔士亲王的座右铭。
Yes. Supposedly comes because John, the blind King of Bohemia, which of course is Czech Republic now, but it was part of the German empire. He, he fought at the battle of Cressy. And when it became obvious that the,
是的。据说是来自波希米亚的盲眼国王约翰，当然现在是捷克共和国，但它曾是德国帝国的一部分。他，他在克雷西战役中作战。当显而易见的是，
the English were winning, he demanded to be led into the heart of the melee. You know, he was blind and cut down, but it was a kind of heroic end. And whose side was he on? He was fighting with the French. He was fighting with the melee. You know, he was blind and cut down, but it was a kind of heroic end. Hold on, whose side was he on? He was fighting with the French. He was fighting with the French.
英格兰人正在获胜，他要求被带入混战的中心。你知道，他是盲人，被砍倒了，但这是一种英雄式的结局。他站在哪一边？他与法国人并肩作战。他与混战并肩作战。你知道，他是盲人，被砍倒了，但这是一种英雄式的结局。等等，他站在哪一边？他与法国人并肩作战。他与法国人并肩作战。
And Edward the Black Prince, you know, he won his spurs at Crecy. He's supposed to have taken this motto as his own. Like all brilliant stories, I think it's not true. So that's never stopped us before. No, exactly. But you're right. I mean, that's basically in in terms of relations between germany and england and the high middle ages that's about it for me i mean it's sort of yeah i suppose it says something about um
而黑太子爱德华，你知道，他在克雷西赢得了他的马刺。他被认为采用了这个座右铭作为他自己的。像所有精彩的故事一样，我认为这不是真的。所以这从来没有阻止过我们。不，完全正确。但你是对的。我的意思是，就中世纪盛期德国和英格兰之间的关系而言，对我来说就是这样，我的意思是，这有点，是的，我想这说明了一些关于
yeah the sort of dearth of stuff that i that i did some had to do some online digging what about richard of cornwall so i very vaguelyuely knew about this. We've talked about him. We've talked about him and King Arthur. Well, he's King John's son, is that right? And he's elected King of Germany. Now, this is one of the strange things about German history in the Middle Ages,
是的，那种资料的匮乏，我不得不做一些在线挖掘。康沃尔的理查德怎么样？所以我模糊地知道这一点。我们谈论过他。我们谈论过他和亚瑟王。嗯，他是约翰国王的儿子，对吧？他被选为德国国王。现在，这是中世纪德国历史中奇怪的事情之一，
that the King of Germany was called King of the Romans. Yes. It's all incredibly confusing. So he was elected King of the Romans, which meant he was the ruler of Germany in 1256. He was crowned in Aachen, in this sort of place where Charlemagne had been crowned. But he only went to Germany four times.
德国国王被称为罗马人之王。是的。这一切都令人难以置信地困惑。所以他在 1256 年被选为罗马人之王，这意味着他是德国的统治者。他在亚琛加冕，在查理曼大帝加冕的地方。但他只去过德国四次。
So he's like a sort of reverse Richard the Lionheart or something. As in, instead of going on crusade, he just spends all... He died in Hertfordshire, very disappointingly, for the King of the Romans, who was also the King of Germany. But he also built Tintagel. Did he? Yes, we did talk about this. Yes, so we talked about him. So this was his sort of...
所以他就像一个反向的狮心王理查德之类的。我的意思是，他没有去十字军东征，而是把所有……他死在赫特福德郡，对于罗马人之王，也就是德国国王来说，这非常令人失望。但他还建造了廷塔杰尔城堡。是吗？是的，我们确实谈论过这个。是的，所以我们谈论过他。所以这是他的那种……
I mean, if I was German, I wouldn't be best pleased with this kind of conduct. Well, the whole thing about kind of electors and palatinates coming from the palace at arkan and palatinate obviously has echo of palatine in rome there is there is a kind of the the um the the way in which basically the guy who rules the patchwork of kingdoms and territories and bishoprics in what becomes germ. He's the emperor of the Romans. And that's the incredible confusion of it and the mess up of it. Whereas England, obviously, you know, the national history is much simpler
我的意思是，如果我是德国人，我对这种行为不会感到高兴。嗯，关于选帝侯和普法尔茨选侯从亚琛的宫殿而来，普法尔茨（Palatinate）显然在罗马有帕拉蒂尼（Palatine）的回响，有一种，嗯，基本上统治着后来成为德国的王国、领土和主教区的拼凑体的家伙。他是罗马人的皇帝。这就是令人难以置信的混乱和一团糟。而英格兰，显然，你知道，民族历史要简单得多，
because the borders are fairly coherent. And there's a kind of consistent national story that you can tell there. And I think, I guess you mentioned the Hanseatic League. I mean, that actually is quite significant because that's a kind of a well it's a kind of proto uh common market isn't it of of yeah of traders and and cities um and they uh they're always forcing unequal trade deals on england yeah i think you care a lot about the hanseatic league don't you if you live in ipswich or something um Yeah, or Lubeck.
因为边界相当连贯。而且有一个你可以讲述的一致的民族故事。我想，我猜你提到了汉萨同盟。我的意思是，这实际上非常重要，因为那是一种，嗯，它是一种原始的共同市场，不是吗？由商人和城市组成，嗯，他们总是强迫英格兰签署不平等的贸易协议。是的，我想如果你住在伊普斯威奇或其他地方，你非常关心汉萨同盟，不是吗？嗯，是的，或者吕贝克。
Yes. Or Hamburg. Yeah, places with stepped gabled roofs. Exactly, and Marzipan. Yeah, yeah. This is profound historical fundatory, Tom. Okay, but on that theme, the Reformation, of course. Well, I was about to say, this is the way it all kicks off, really, isn't it? I mean, it does kind of.
是的。或者汉堡。是的，有阶梯式山墙屋顶的地方。没错，还有杏仁糖。是的，是的。这是深刻的历史基础，汤姆。好吧，关于这个主题，宗教改革，当然。嗯，我正要说，这真的是一切开始的方式，不是吗？我的意思是，确实有点。
I mean, obviously, without Luther, there is no Reformation, and therefore there is no Reformation in England. So clearly, that generates a lot of communion, as it were. Yeah. But it's telling that England's form of Protestantism is not Lutheran. So unlike the Protestantism in, say scandinavia which is lutheran england's isn't england's is essentially calvinist and calvin of course is french oh so yeah we've the old francophilia rearing it yeah well yet again you see the way in which the the continental power that is has the greatest influence on us is invariably france so even in
我的意思是，显然，没有路德，就没有宗教改革，因此英格兰也就没有宗教改革。所以很明显，这产生了很多交流。是的。但令人深思的是，英格兰的新教形式不是路德宗。所以不像斯堪的纳维亚的新教是路德宗，英格兰的不是，英格兰的本质上是加尔文宗，而加尔文当然是法国人。哦，所以是的，我们有旧的亲法倾向在抬头，是的，嗯，又一次，你看到了大陆强权对我们影响最大的方式总是法国，所以即使在
the reformation because Germany is still divided I suppose I'll tell you a good fact in everybody in their wallet if they look in their wallets those people who still have kind of cash on your pound coin you have two letters which is a kind of little emblem of Anglo-German antagonism because it's the FD Fidei Defensor which was awarded to Henry VIII wasn't it after he his book, the first book published by an English monarch in which he attacked Martin Luther. Yes. So this is Henry coming out against Luther. You know what Luther
宗教改革中，因为德国仍然分裂，我想我会告诉你一个好事实，每个人在他们的钱包里，如果他们看他们的钱包，那些仍然有现金的人，在你的英镑硬币上有两个字母，这是英德对抗的一种小标志，因为它是 FD（Fidei Defensor，信仰捍卫者），这是亨利八世被授予的，不是吗？在他出版了他的书之后，这是第一本由英国君主出版的书，他在书中攻击了马丁·路德。是的。所以这是亨利站出来反对路德。你知道路德
said about Henry after Henry VIII wrote that? Remind me. He said he was a pig, an ass, a dunghill, the spawn of an adder, a basilisk, a lying buffoon, and a mad fool with a frothy mouth. So I'll put him down as undecided then.
在亨利八世写了那本书后是怎么评价亨利的吗？提醒我一下。他说他是一头猪、一头驴、一堆粪、一条毒蛇的后代、一只蛇怪、一个撒谎的小丑和一个口吐白沫的疯子。所以我把他归为未决定。
Yeah, I've had reviews like that, to be fair. But even when Henry chucked the Pope out, Luther was still incredibly suspicious of him and accused him essentially of trying to make himself God. Yeah, well, he wasn't entirely wrong. Yeah, it's a lot of unfair criticism um but at that stage the interesting thing is tom that there doesn't seem to be a sense in england of sort of german-ness i guess of of a german is there i mean germany is still very divided obviously henry then goes on to marry the
是的，公平地说，我收到过那样的评论。但即使亨利把教皇赶走时，路德仍然对他极其怀疑，并基本上指责他试图让自己成为上帝。是的，嗯，他并不完全错误。是的，有很多不公平的批评，嗯，但在那个阶段，有趣的是，汤姆，英格兰似乎没有一种德国性的感觉，我猜，德国人，我的意思是，德国显然仍然非常分裂，亨利随后娶了
anne of cleves who's from what is effectively, I guess, sort of Dutch-German borderlands. But there's no sort of sense of the Germans having a distinct identity and a kind of national temperament and all those things that we would associate with the French in this period. I think there's a sense that the Germans are drunkards, which I think coming from the English is a bit rich. Yeah. But I agree. there's a sense that the germans are drunkards which i think coming from the english is a bit rich yeah but i think i agree i mean that i i don't think that there is a kind of strong sense of of you're right about that and i think but i think that changes in the 17th century
克莱沃的安妮，她来自我猜实际上是荷兰-德国边境地区。但没有一种德国人有独特身份和民族气质的感觉，以及我们在这一时期与法国人联系在一起的所有那些事情。我认为有一种感觉是德国人是酒鬼，我认为这来自英国人有点过分了。是的。但我同意。有一种感觉是德国人是酒鬼，我认为这来自英国人有点过分了。是的，但我认为我同意，我的意思是，我不认为有一种强烈的……你是对的，关于这一点，我认为，但我认为这在 17 世纪发生了变化。
why because of the 30 years war or because of i think yes well but but also because James I's daughter, Elizabeth, who is, of course, Charles I's sister, marries into German dynastic politics. And therefore, England becomes enmeshed both in the dynastic politics of it, but also in the religious divide. And there's a sense in which in the 17th century, kind of Puritan opinion in England is following the fortunes of Protestants in the German empire, perhaps in the way that the left now follow the fortunes of, say, the Palestinians. There's this passionate of passionate committed engagement with what is going on in in the german empire and it's it's much more intense and in a sense i mean it's it's it's crucially important for england in all kinds of ways because it feeds into the
为什么？因为三十年战争还是因为……我认为是的，嗯，但也因为詹姆斯一世的女儿伊丽莎白，当然是查理一世的妹妹，嫁入了德国的王朝政治。因此，英格兰既卷入了德国的王朝政治，也卷入了宗教分裂。在 17 世纪，英格兰的清教徒舆论在某种程度上追随德国帝国新教徒的命运，也许就像左派现在追随巴勒斯坦人的命运一样。有一种对德国帝国正在发生的事情的充满激情的投入，而且它更强烈，在某种意义上，我的意思是，它对英格兰在各方面都至关重要，因为它助长了
civil war and then in the long run it feeds into the um the dynastic um transformation that happens with the expulsion of james ii yeah and the arrival of the hanoverians i love all that tom i remember doing it at school this is a sort of slightly pitiful memory but um at school uh we were talking about you know james i and his battles with parliament and our teacher said you know what you now have to bear in mind is the reaction to the battle of white mountain at the beginning of the 30 years war and that was one of the first moments studying history that i really appreciated how events in one sphere could have a massive political impact on events that appeared to be in an so in other
内战，从长远来看，它助长了随着詹姆斯二世被驱逐而发生的王朝转型，是的，以及汉诺威王朝的到来。我喜欢这一切，汤姆，我记得在学校学过这个，这是一个稍微有点可怜的记忆，但嗯，在学校，我们谈论詹姆斯一世和他与议会的斗争，我们的老师说，你知道你现在必须记住的是对三十年战争开始时白山战役的反应，这是我学习历史时第一次真正体会到在一个领域发生的事件如何对看似在另一个领域的事件产生巨大的政治影响，所以换句话说，
words people were following exactly as you say people politicians and people interested in politics were following events in germany with the same passion that they followed say the spanish civil war in the 1930s and they saw it as a sort of reflection of english politics or english politics as a reflection of it yes because um elizabeth marries frederick um who is the elector palatine of the rhine which is one of those kind of classic titles that they very much have in germany at this this period and he inevitably gets elected um king of bohemia and he it's not a great success because he's protestant and the catholic powers are not keen on having a protestant king in prague and so he's derisively called the winter king because he basically rules for the span of a winter. And so he loses the Battle of the White Mountain in 1620, I think it is.
人们正在追随，正如你所说，政治家和对政治感兴趣的人正在以与他们追随 20 世纪 30 年代西班牙内战相同的热情追随德国的事件，他们将其视为英国政治的一种反映，或者英国政治是它的一种反映。是的，因为嗯，伊丽莎白嫁给了莱茵河的普法尔茨选侯弗雷德里克，这是这一时期德国非常典型的经典头衔之一，他不可避免地被选为波希米亚国王，这不是一个巨大的成功，因为他是新教徒，而天主教势力并不热衷于在布拉格有一个新教国王，所以他被嘲讽地称为“冬王”，因为他基本上只统治了一个冬天。所以他在 1620 年（我想是这样）输掉了白山战役。
Yeah, it's something like that, isn't it? And he's forced to flee and he nicks the Bohemian crown jewels and scrams him and his wife and his children. And they end up in the Dutch Republic, which is like England, is one of the great power centers of Protestantism. And there is huge, huge sympathy for them. And people in England are kind of raising money for them and hoping that he will get his fortunes restored. But it kind of plays out in an interesting way for Puritan opinion because Frederick and Elizabeth's third son is Rupert.
是的，差不多是这样，不是吗？他被迫逃亡，偷走了波希米亚的王冠珠宝，带着他的妻子和孩子逃跑了。他们最终来到了荷兰共和国，这就像英格兰一样，是新教的伟大权力中心之一。人们对他们有巨大的同情。英格兰的人们正在为他们筹款，希望他能恢复他的财富。但这对于清教徒舆论来说以一种有趣的方式展开，因为弗雷德里克和伊丽莎白的第三个儿子是鲁珀特。
Yeah. Comes to be known as, of course, Rupert of the Rhine because he's the son of the Elector Palatine of the Rhine. But as Charles I's nephew, he's the great dashing exemplar of the cavalier in the Civil Wars. He's the guy who's rushing around kind of burning down birmingham and leading the attack at marston moore he's a great character i mean he is one of the great characters in all anglo-german history indeed in all english history i think the great one of the there's so many things to talk about prince rupert so one of them is he's he's famous as this great dashing commander but he basically never wins an important battle he loses but he loses with such dash but he does with the dash right the dash he's come
是的。当然，他被称为莱茵河的鲁珀特，因为他是莱茵河普法尔茨选侯的儿子。但作为查理一世的侄子，他是内战中骑士党的伟大冲锋典范。他就是那个到处烧毁伯明翰并在马斯顿荒原战役中领导进攻的家伙，他是一个伟大的人物，我的意思是，他是所有英德历史中，甚至所有英国历史中的伟大人物之一，我认为，关于鲁珀特亲王有太多事情要谈了，所以其中之一是，他以这位伟大的冲锋指挥官而闻名，但他基本上从未赢得过一场重要的战斗，他输了，但他输得如此有冲劲，但他确实有冲劲，对吧？冲劲，他来自
from germany so the 30 years war is going on and and one thing that i think english sort of people even if they're quite interested in history never really appreciate is just how unbelievably ghastly and apocalyptic the 30 years war is so germany loses i don't know a quarter of its population or something some colossal yeah there was a poll i think taken five years after the second world war where germans were asked to vote on on the worst thing that had happened in german history this is five years after the second world war and they voted for the 30 years war yeah i mean it's absolutely sort of engraved in german in the german historical imagination, isn't it? And in England, I mean, people obviously followed it, as we said at the time.
德国，所以三十年战争正在进行，我认为英国人即使对历史很感兴趣，也从未真正体会到三十年战争是多么令人难以置信的恐怖和末日。所以德国失去了，我不知道，四分之一的人口还是什么，一些巨大的……是的，我想在第二次世界大战后五年进行了一次民意调查，德国人被要求投票选出德国历史上发生的最糟糕的事情，这是在第二次世界大战后五年，他们投票选出了三十年战争。是的，我的意思是，它绝对是刻在德国历史想象中的，不是吗？而在英格兰，我的意思是，人们显然像我们说的那样在当时关注它。
But now it's kind of forgotten, just seen as utterly impenetrable, which it kind of is. But Rupert was used to the atrocities and the sort of terrible behavior of the Thirty Years' War. And he brought some of that to England and got a very bad reputation with the parliamentarians. Because, as you say, he went around burning towns and massacring people and stuff because he thought this was completely reasonable I mean I hope the Germans don't bring this to cricket if this if you know in similar terrible if they did well he's he's let's let's he's Anglo he's Anglo-German but but but his his you're right his ethos is essentially you know he's essentially German and and so I would say that he's the first great German to impact on the English national consciousness.
但现在它被遗忘了，只是被视为完全不可理解，这在某种程度上确实如此。但鲁珀特习惯了三十年战争的暴行和那种可怕的行为。他把其中的一些带到了英格兰，并在议会派中名声很差。因为，正如你所说，他到处烧毁城镇和屠杀人们之类的，因为他认为这完全合理。我的意思是，我希望德国人不要把这个带到板球比赛中，如果这，你知道，在类似的糟糕情况下，如果他们真的……嗯，他是，让我们，让我们，他是盎格鲁人，他是盎格鲁-德国人，但但但他的，你是对的，他的精神本质上是，你知道，他本质上是德国人，所以我认为他是第一个影响英国民族意识的伟大德国人。
And he's supposed to have had his dog boy. I mean, dogs have been a feature of this podcast in recent weeks. I think it would be wrong not to mention his dog. Who is supposed to be a white poodle. Yes. Supposed by his Puritan enemies to have been his witches familiar. And dies at Marston Moor, I think. He could find treasure.
而且他被认为有一只狗，男孩。我的意思是，狗在最近几周一直是这个播客的一个特色。我认为不提他的狗是不对的。谁被认为是白色的贵宾犬。是的。被他的清教徒敌人认为是他的女巫使魔。而且死在马斯顿荒原，我想。他能找到宝藏。
He could foretell the future. And he could catch bullets in his mouth. Yes. Which for a commander's dog is an immense skill, I would say. But then he dies at Marston Moor. And from that point on, Prince Rupert's lost his superpower. Yeah. And everything goes wrong.
他能预知未来。他能用嘴接住子弹。是的。对于指挥官的狗来说，这是一项巨大的技能，我会说。但后来他死在马斯顿荒原。从那时起，鲁珀特亲王失去了他的超能力。是的。一切都出错了。
I was going to say he sticks around. So Prince Rupert is around for another... He's an admiral. He becomes... He's the third person to join the Royal Society, the Great Scientific Society. And he invents things. He invents kinds of guns and grenades and gunpowder.
我正要说他留下来了。所以鲁珀特亲王又待了……他是一名海军上将。他成为……他是第三个加入皇家学会（伟大的科学学会）的人。他发明东西。他发明各种枪支、手榴弹和火药。
Yeah, he's a remarkable man. Yeah, it's Prince Philip, basically. And he sponsors colonial expansion. So there are loads of places in Canada called Rupert after him. Is that so? So he's a very interesting man. One for the Canadian listeners there. Yes, absolutely.
是的，他是一个非凡的人。是的，他基本上就是菲利普亲王。而且他赞助殖民扩张。所以加拿大有很多地方以他的名字命名为鲁珀特。是这样吗？所以他是一个非常有趣的人。为那里的加拿大听众准备的。是的，绝对是。
We want to get Canada in as well. But really, I mean, he's a fascinating figure. And perhaps, I mean, it'd be good to do a whole episode on him, to be honest. But probably a more important figure for the future of Anglo-German relations is his sister, Sophia. So that's the Electoress of Hanover, or the Elector of Hanover's wife or mother or whatever. And so what happens after you have the restoration, Charles II comes back.
我们也想把加拿大拉进来。但真的，我的意思是，他是一个迷人的人物。也许，我的意思是，老实说，做一个关于他的完整剧集会很好。但对于英德关系的未来来说，可能更重要的人物是他的妹妹索菲亚。所以那是汉诺威选侯夫人，或者汉诺威选侯的妻子或母亲什么的。所以，在复辟之后，查理二世回来了，发生了什么。
He was a kind of crypto-Catholic. His brother, James II, who succeeds Charles II, is an open Catholic. And that then precipitates a Protestant meltdown. And so you have the Glorious Revolution of 1688. William III comes from Holland, from the Netherlands. Yeah. With his wife, Mary. Mary's sister Anne then follows, but neither of them have children.
他是一个秘密的天主教徒。继查理二世之后的詹姆斯二世是一个公开的天主教徒。这随后引发了新教的崩溃。所以你有了 1688 年的光荣革命。威廉三世来自荷兰，来自尼德兰。是的。带着他的妻子玛丽。玛丽的妹妹安妮随后继位，但他们都没有孩子。
And so Britain faces the problem of what king do we get? Where do we get a Protestant monarchy? And so they turn to Sophia, whose son, George, who is the elector of Hanover, comes over and becomes George I. Yeah, this is absolutely seismic moment, isn't it? So the 18th century, the Hanoverian age, the relations of Britain and Germany are completely intertwined. And one thing that surprises me about this is that we always think of the Georges as terribly stolid, and in many ways they were the early Georges. But when George I pitches up, there are colossal riots all across England. So on his coronation day, 20th of October 1714,
所以英国面临着我们得到什么国王的问题？我们在哪里得到一个新教君主制？所以他们转向了索菲亚，她的儿子乔治，也就是汉诺威选侯，过来成为了乔治一世。是的，这是一个绝对地震般的时刻，不是吗？所以 18 世纪，汉诺威时代，英国和德国的关系完全交织在一起。有一件事让我感到惊讶，我们总是认为乔治们非常呆板，在许多方面他们是早期的乔治们。但当乔治一世出现时，整个英格兰都发生了巨大的骚乱。所以在他加冕的那天，1714 年 10 月 20 日，
you mentioned Birmingham. So clearly Birmingham has rebuilt itself after being attacked by Prince Ruber, but perhaps it's not forgiven the Germans for this behaviour because there's these massive riots in Birmingham. People are going around shouting, kill the old rogue, kill them all, down with the roundheads. Now, the roundheads, they're obviously not talking about Germans. That's the squareheads, isn't it?
你提到了伯明翰。所以显然伯明翰在被鲁珀特亲王袭击后重建了自己，但也许它没有原谅德国人的这种行为，因为伯明翰发生了这些大规模的骚乱。人们到处喊着，杀死那个老流氓，杀了他们所有人，打倒圆颅党。现在，圆颅党，他们显然不是在谈论德国人。那是方头党（squareheads），不是吗？
The First World War mockery of the Germans. George I has been championed by the square heads, isn't it? The First World War, mockery of the Germans. But they're talking, George I has been championed by the Whigs, by the sort of inheritors of the revolution of the mid 17th century, by the sort of descendants of the parliamentarians, I suppose. And there's these colossal, and George, they actually don't really manage
第一次世界大战对德国人的嘲弄。乔治一世一直被方头党支持，不是吗？第一次世界大战，对德国人的嘲弄。但他们正在谈论，乔治一世一直被辉格党支持，被 17 世纪中叶革命的继承者，被议会派的后代支持，我想。而且有这些巨大的，而且乔治，他们实际上并没有真正设法
to clamp down on it. So they don't, a lot of people don't get punished because the rights are so widespread. But George just sort of ignores them in his stolid Teutonic way. And you know what, George, something that greatly surprised me, he was a big admirer of double entendres. Was he? Yeah.
镇压它。所以他们没有，很多人没有受到惩罚，因为骚乱太普遍了。但乔治只是以他呆板的条顿方式忽略了他们。你知道吗，乔治，有一件事让我非常惊讶，他是一个双关语的崇拜者。是吗？是的。
But not in English, obviously, because he didn't speak German. No, in German. Well, I think this is contested, actually. Some people say he actually spoke a bit more English than was previously thought. But he did like bawdy humour. He was a very... And there was a lot of talk that he was sort of bringing over all these German mistresses and things.
但显然不是用英语，因为他不会说德语。不，用德语。嗯，我认为这实际上是有争议的。有些人说他实际上说的英语比以前认为的要多。但他确实喜欢下流的幽默。他是一个非常……而且有很多传言说他带来了所有这些德国情妇之类的。
So I think maybe he's a sort of German Sid James. Maybe that's the way... Is that your Sid James laugh? I like down with the roundheads as a chant. Yeah. I wouldn't chant that because I'm a roundhead. I can imagine you on the terraces shouting that at the German team. Yeah, of course.
所以我认为也许他是一个德国版的西德·詹姆斯（Sid James）。也许这就是方式……那是你的西德·詹姆斯笑声吗？我喜欢“打倒圆颅党”作为口号。是的。我不会喊那个，因为我是圆颅党。我可以想象你在看台上对德国队喊那个。是的，当然。
Historically informed chant. Yeah. And he, of course, brings over Handel, the great, you know, the sort of… The great slaver. Well, yes. The titanic figure of English music, George Frederick Handel. And these sort of great moments of English 18th century music are, of course, German.
历史知情的口号。是的。而且他当然带来了亨德尔，伟大的，你知道，那种……伟大的奴隶贩子。嗯，是的。英国音乐的泰坦人物，乔治·弗雷德里克·亨德尔。而这些英国 18 世纪音乐的伟大时刻，当然是德国的。
So that sort of kickstarts a romance. And it's George II, isn't he? He stands, he listens to the Messiah and he hears the Alleluia Chorus and he's so struck by it that he stands up and applauds. That's a nice story. Yeah, and I think that
所以这开启了一段浪漫史。那是乔治二世，不是吗？他站着，他听《弥赛亚》，他听到了《哈利路亚大合唱》，他被深深打动了，以至于他站起来鼓掌。那是一个不错的故事。是的，而且我认为
it's now the tradition when you go to the Messiah that you stand up. Really? The Alleluia Chorus. You don't want to get that wrong, do you? You don't want to stand up
现在当你去听《弥赛亚》时，站起来是传统。真的吗？《哈利路亚大合唱》。你不想弄错，对吧？你不想站起来
and applaud and no one else. But if you're the king, you can do that. And also, of course, George II, the other great famous thing
鼓掌而没有其他人这样做。但如果你是国王，你可以那样做。而且，当然，乔治二世，另一个伟大的著名事情
about George II is that he's the last British monarch to lead an army. In Germany at the Battle of Dettingen, isn't it? Yes, where he almost loses. I mean, he's a terrible general.
关于乔治二世的是，他是最后一位率领军队的英国君主。在德国的代廷根战役，不是吗？是的，他在那里差点输了。我的意思是，他是一个糟糕的将军。
Well, that's obviously a theme because there must be something Germanic in that because that's Prince Rupert as well. But that's an interesting story in itself. So that obviously often – we did the Seven Years' War podcast, didn't we? And one thing that's often lost from all of this sort of story of 18th century britain as it becomes and britain's expansion um is that we are involved in europe the whole time and for the hanoverian kings the protection of hanover and their involvement in german affairs was immensely important to them so all this time in a way that we've now forgotten britain was enmeshed in the sort of incredibly arcane politics
嗯，这显然是一个主题，因为那里面一定有什么日耳曼的东西，因为那也是鲁珀特亲王。但那本身就是一个有趣的故事。所以这显然经常——我们做了七年战争的播客，不是吗？而且从所有这些 18 世纪英国扩张的故事中经常丢失的一件事是，我们一直卷入欧洲，对于汉诺威国王来说，保护汉诺威和他们对德国事务的参与对他们来说非常重要。所以所有这些时间，以一种我们现在已经忘记的方式，英国被卷入了那种令人难以置信的神秘政治
of the Germanic world. And George II is very, very effective at ensuring that British arms and money is used to defend his territories in Germany. Yes. I mean, actually, this is something that some scholars, so there's a guy called Brendan Sims who's written a massive, colossal book about this, arguing that for all that we're now fixated with empire
日耳曼世界。而乔治二世在确保英国的武器和金钱被用于保卫他在德国的领土方面非常、非常有效。是的。我的意思是，实际上，这是某些学者所说的，所以有一个叫布伦丹·西姆斯的人写了一本关于这个的巨大、庞大的书，认为尽管我们现在沉迷于帝国
and with colonial expansion, that actually this was merely a means to an end and that what mattered to the monarch and most of the elite was exactly as you say, the balance of power within Central Europe and all the other stuff, the acquiring of colonies and the ships and was just a weapon site was was a just a
和殖民扩张，但实际上这仅仅是达到目的的一种手段，对君主和大多数精英来说，真正重要的是正如你所说，中欧内部的权力平衡，以及所有其他东西，获得殖民地和船只，只是这场战争中的一个武器点，主要是为了控制他们的大陆而对抗法国人，所以我们谈论了七年战争播客中的这一点，即英国和普鲁士在某种程度上成为了天然盟友，是的，这显然是随后延续到拿破仑时代的事情，是的，那正是普鲁士，通常的联盟变成了英国和普鲁士，不是吗？而且我认为正是在那个时候，肯定到了 19 世纪，这种祖先的，你知道，友谊的想法，即有某种亲缘关系。
weapon in this war largely against the french for control of their sort of continent and so we took we talked about that in the seven years war podcast that that britain and prussia kind of become natural allies um yes and that is obviously something that then carries through into the napoleonic era yeah that exactly Prussia, the usual alliance becomes Britain and Prussia, doesn't it? And I think it's at that point, certainly by the 19th century, that this idea of the ancestral, you know, friendship, that there's sort of ties of kinship.
我的意思是，那显然是维多利亚时代的。它体现在惠灵顿和布吕歇尔在滑铁卢的杀戮中相遇。这就是德国人和英国人看待彼此的基础形象，肯定是在
I mean, that's obviously something Victorian. It's embodied in Wellington and Bucha kind of meeting each other amid the carnage of Waterloo. And that is the kind of foundational image for the way that the Germans and the British see each other, certainly in the first years
19 世纪的最初几年。所以布吕歇尔和腓特烈大帝以及普鲁士军队的想法显然是我们可能会反向投射的东西，因为我们知道它将导致什么。但远离普鲁士，你仍然有所有这些选侯国、普法尔茨选侯国和主教区之类的。然后拿破仑摆脱了它们，然后从拿破仑时代走出来
of the 19th century. So Blucher and Frederick the Great and the idea of Prussian arms is obviously something that we might back project because we know where it's going to lead. But away from Prussia, you've still got all these kind of electorates and palatants and bishoprics and things. And then Napoleon gets rid of them and then coming out of the Napoleonic era
你面临着德国应该是什么的问题。嗯，在那一点上，我认为你有两件事，汤姆，一，你有普鲁士的扩张，所以德国将成为，它从来没有真正成为一种特别
you've got the problem of what should Germany be Well at that point you've got two things I think Tom one you've got Prussia expanding so Germany is going to become which has never really been a sort of a particularly
强有力的政治概念，将成为 19 世纪的一种政治概念。但你也有法国的衰落。而且我认为英国与德国的关系在法国开始衰落后发生了变化。因为我们的友谊是如此紧密地建立在对法国人的共同厌恶之上。但我认为这种“德国应该是什么”的想法还有另一个维度，它来自法国大革命和拿破仑战争，那就是它产生了一种，嗯，军国主义者，但几乎是完全相反的，梦想家和思想家，他们的头脑迷失在云端。这就是那种歌德和卡斯帕·大卫·弗里德里希的画作
potent political concept is going to become a political concept in really been a particularly potent political concept, is going to become a political concept in the 19th century. But also you have the decline of France. And I think the British relationship with Germany changes once France starts to decline. Because our friendship was spaced so tightly on a shared loathing of the French. But I think there's another dimension to this kind of what should Germany be that comes out of the French Revolution and the Napoleonic Wars, which is that it generates a kind of kind of militarists, but of almost the precise opposite, kind of dreamers and thinkers whose head are lost in the cloud. It's the sort of Goethe and Caspar David Friedrich paintings
人们看着山谷，感觉非常悲惨。是的，在山上，凝视着雾气之类的。所以你有像塞缪尔·泰勒·柯勒律治这样的人，伟大的诗人，你知道，和威廉·华兹华斯一起写《抒情歌谣集》，他是去德国学习德语的伟大浪漫主义人物之一，然后基本上回来重述了他所学到的所有这种唯心主义哲学。这对英国人如何看待德国人有着巨大的、巨大的影响。所以我认为，你知道，我们还没有 45 分钟，但哨声应该吹响了，我们应该去休息一下。
of people looking at valleys and feeling very miserable. Yes, on mountains and gazing at mist and things. And so you've got someone like Samuel Taylor Coleridge, the great poet, you know, with William Wordsworth writing the lyrical ballads, one of the great romantic figures who goes to Germany and learns German and then basically comes back and regurgitates all this idealist philosophy that he's picked up. And that's hugely, hugely influential on how the British see the Germans. So I think, you know, we haven't had 45 minutes, but the whistle should blow and we should go and have a brief interval.
但我认为这是一个离开的好点。一个非常快乐的点，是的。把德国人看作是无效的、无能的梦想家，他们非常擅长哲学。所以这个播客将变成像斯文-约兰·埃里克森对英格兰表现的评价。上半场不错，下半场不太好。休息后见。
But I think it's a good point to leave it. A very happy point, yeah. Seeing the Germans as ineffectual, incompetent dreamers who are very good at philosophy. So this podcast is going to turn out like Sven-Joran Eriksson's verdict on English performances. First half good, second half not so good. I'll see you after the break.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、加更剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》，我是多米尼克·桑布鲁克和汤姆·霍兰德。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History with me Domin Dominic Samrook, and Tom Holland.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》。这是您每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕后真相，为您讲述这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想收听无广告内容、获取额外剧集并优先购买现场演出门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史余谈》，我是多米尼克·桑布鲁克，还有汤姆·霍兰德。
And we are talking England and Germany, or Britain and Germany, I suppose, since we're into the 19th century. And Tom, I think an absolutely central figure in all this is Prince Albert, who we haven't discussed yet. Yes, who, of course, ends up marrying Queen Victoria. victoria and again we were talking before the uh before the break that the image of germany is is um they're ineffectual they're basically not very rich um and that's that's very much the kind of opinion on prince albert isn't it he's he's not quite seen he's seen as punching above his weight i think he is in victoria he is the paradigmatic example of the consort who arrives and everybody despises him and they say who is this jumped up foreigner and why should we listen to him? So a lot of people say Saxe Coburg, which is where he's from, is smaller than an English county.
我们谈论的是英国和德国，或者说是英国和普鲁士，我想，毕竟我们已经进入了19世纪。汤姆，我认为这一切的核心人物是阿尔伯特亲王，我们还没讨论过他。是的，他当然最终娶了维多利亚女王。维多利亚，我们刚才在休息前谈到，德国的形象是……他们效率低下，基本上不太富裕，这在很大程度上也是人们对阿尔伯特亲王的看法，不是吗？他被认为有些名不副实，我想在维多利亚女王眼中，他是那种典型的配偶，刚到时每个人都鄙视他，他们说：“这个暴发户外国人是谁？我们为什么要听他的？”所以很多人说萨克森-科堡，也就是他的家乡，比英国的一个郡还要小。
And of course, what makes this sort of worse is two things. One, that Queen Victoria is utterly devoted to him. You know, if you read her sort of diary entries, you know, oh, what a night I spent in his arms and all this kind of business but also prince albert is prince albert is in many ways an immensely admirable man but he's also i imagine incredibly annoying because he arrives he arrives from germany and you can imagine him speaking you know perfect german accented english and he sort of says your child labor is very unacceptable you know you should clean up this you should do that. You should have a great exhibition. You should all this. But that's all great, Dominic.
当然，让情况变得更糟的是两件事。第一，维多利亚女王对他极其痴迷。你知道，如果你读她的日记，你会看到“哦，我在他怀里度过了多么美妙的一夜”之类的。但另一方面，阿尔伯特亲王在许多方面是一个令人极其钦佩的人，但我猜他也会让人感到无比烦人，因为他从德国来到这里，你可以想象他操着一口完美的德语口音英语，然后说：“你们的童工制度太不可接受了，你们应该清理一下这个，做做那个。你们应该举办一场伟大的博览会。”等等。但这些都很棒，多米尼克。
That's all great stuff. Yeah, but he's got all these improving ideas. You're the voice of Flashman. I mean, that's the worst thing, you see, that he's got all these brilliant, very good ideas, very admirable ideas. And coming from this guy from Saxe-Coburg, a lot of people sort of shake their heads grumpily.
这些都很棒。是的，但他有所有这些改良主义的想法。你是弗莱什曼的代言人。我的意思是，这是最糟糕的事情，你看，他有所有这些绝妙的、非常好的想法，非常令人钦佩的想法。而这些想法出自这个来自萨克森-科堡的家伙之口，很多人只能没好气地摇摇头。
But over time, I think he wins people over because he's sort of aggressive, modernising ideas. You can't argue with them. I mean, their child labour is hard to defend. But also the Great Exhibition, which is essentially his scheme, is a great success. It is. And it ends up funding all the museums,
但随着时间的推移，我认为他赢得了人们的支持，因为他那些激进的现代化思想是无法反驳的。我的意思是，他们的童工制度很难辩护。而且，本质上是他策划的“万国工业博览会”也取得了巨大成功。确实如此。它最终资助了所有的博物馆，
Victoria and Albert Museum most obviously, but others as well in South Kensington. And that's a permanent memorial to him. Yeah, absolutely. I mean, there's memorials. It's got that kind of massive gold statue of him surrounded by emblems of the empire, which I'm amazed hasn't been cancelled yet.
最明显的是维多利亚和阿尔伯特博物馆，南肯辛顿的其他博物馆也是如此。那是他永久的纪念碑。是的，绝对是。我的意思是，有很多纪念碑。他有一座巨大的金色雕像，周围环绕着帝国的象征，我很惊讶它竟然还没有被“取消”。
And when he died, I mean, people put up memorials all over the country. There's a memorial in Wolverhampton, Tom, you'll be pleased to hear. Yeah, Prince Albert on a horse in the middle of Wolverhampton. It's good to see the Midlands getting reconciled at last to Germany. Yes.
他去世时，人们在全国各地竖立了纪念碑。汤姆，你一定会很高兴听到，伍尔弗汉普顿也有一座纪念碑。是的，伍尔弗汉普顿市中心有一座骑马的阿尔伯特亲王雕像。很高兴看到中部地区终于与德国和解了。是的。
After Prince Rupert. Yeah, after Prince Rupert and after the riots in Birmingham and George I, the Midlands finally, exactly, discovered its inner Teuton. But also the Christmas tree. The Christmas tree is Albert's lasting legacy. Because I think there have been Christmas trees before, but he really popularises the idea of the Christmas tree.
继鲁珀特亲王之后。是的，在鲁珀特亲王之后，在伯明翰骚乱和乔治一世之后，中部地区终于，没错，发现了它内在的条顿精神。还有圣诞树。圣诞树是阿尔伯特留下的持久遗产。因为我认为在那之前也有圣诞树，但他真正普及了圣诞树的概念。
So we owe him so much, Tom. So it's all good looking good, isn't it? For Anglo-German relations. It's great. And actually right up to 1870. A little bit beyond that, but I think 1870 is the key turning point. Because that, of course, is the moment when Bismarck,
所以我们欠他太多了，汤姆。所以一切看起来都不错，不是吗？对于英德关系来说。这很棒。实际上一直持续到1870年。稍微超出了一点，但我认为1870年是一个关键的转折点。因为那当然是俾斯麦的时刻，
basically, I mean, we talked about this with Katja Hoyer in our Second Reich podcast. She manoeuvres the French. Sorry, she. Katja. Katja doesn't. Yeah. She's got a Bismarckian side to her, I think, Katja. Anyway, Bismarck manoeuvres the French into war.
基本上，我的意思是，我们在我们的“第二帝国”播客中和卡佳·霍耶谈过这个。她操纵了法国人。抱歉，她。卡佳。卡佳没有。是的。我认为卡佳有俾斯麦的一面。总之，俾斯麦操纵法国人卷入了战争。
The Prussians wipe the floor with the French. And it's then that they create the second then by they create germany the thing i think from 1870 onwards you can see this growing disquiet but at the time there's quite a lot of enthusiasm for germany's victory isn't there there's all this kind of press reports we are glad to see sober industrious moral germany triumph over yeah catholic fame gloriousious cockerels of France. Yeah, but I think then, sort of about a week later, it's like the hangover.
普鲁士人把法国人打得落花流水。然后他们创造了第二个帝国，通过这种方式他们创造了德国。我认为从1870年开始，你可以看到这种日益增长的不安，但当时人们对德国的胜利有很多热情，不是吗？到处都是那种新闻报道，我们很高兴看到清醒、勤奋、道德高尚的德国战胜了……是的，天主教那些虚荣、光荣的法国公鸡。是的，但我想大约一周后，就像宿醉一样。
They kind of wake up and think, oh, God. They're going to be beating us at football soon. Yes, and I also said this moment, that once Germany's unified, the tremendous engines of German capitalism really start to roar. And so by the end of the 19th century, German manufacturing has caught up with and it is indeed is overtaking british manufacturing and then you
他们醒悟过来，心想，天哪。他们很快就要在足球上打败我们了。是的，我也说过这个时刻，一旦德国统一，德国资本主义的巨大引擎就开始轰鸣。所以到了19世纪末，德国制造业已经赶上并确实正在超越英国制造业，然后你
get this moment these moments which we talked about before of um you know this sort of slightly paranoid fantasies i mean you could argue they don't turn out to be so paranoid after all that the germans are about to invade that the germans have overtaken us. Through the Dorking Gap. Yes, exactly. We talked about the invasion of 1910 and all these kinds of things. But I think it's more than that as well. I mean, it's not just military, is it, or even industrial. It's also the sense that the Germans are more civilised. Yes. That they are kind of beating us pretty much in every cultural field.
就会遇到这些我们之前谈过的时刻，那种稍微有点偏执的幻想——我的意思是，你可以说它们最终并非那么偏执——德国人即将入侵，德国人已经超越了我们。通过多金缺口。是的，没错。我们谈到了1910年的入侵以及所有这些事情。但我认为这不仅仅是军事上的，甚至不仅仅是工业上的。这也是一种感觉，即德国人更文明。是的。他们在几乎所有的文化领域都在打败我们。
Yeah, their laboratories, their universities. Their universities set the template um and i think it's the for the first time the english feel an inferiority complex and so they respond in the obvious way by building huge massive phallic warships yeah well of course there's the dreadnought race there's the dreadnought race before they i mean i think the um the sort of obsession with national virility is is shared on both sides so i mean we talked think the sort of obsession with national virility is shared on both sides. So, I mean, we talked, obviously, the Kaiser and his boating shoes. Yes, a cow.
是的，他们的实验室，他们的大学。他们的大学树立了模板，我认为这是英国人第一次感到自卑，所以他们以显而易见的方式回应，建造巨大、雄伟的阳具型战舰。是的，当然有无畏舰竞赛，在他们之前有无畏舰竞赛。我的意思是，我认为那种对国家阳刚之气的痴迷在双方都是共有的。所以，我的意思是，我们谈到了，显然，德皇和他的划船鞋。是的，一头牛。
For the third time, I get to mention them. He gets laughter. So that's one thing where we do uphold is that we have proper yachting etiquette. And the Kaiser is lamentably gauche at such issues. So there at least, Britannia rules the wave you you have formed yourself on this don't you i mean terrible yes didn't mean you sympathize with the kaiser i mean you're quite similar people in many ways i think and um well yeah well let's not pursue that analogy but yes before the first world war i think there were two things going on one is the anxiety and
这是我第三次提到它们。他引来了笑声。所以这是我们确实坚持的一点，那就是我们有适当的游艇礼仪。而德皇在这些问题上显得极其笨拙。所以至少在那一点上，不列颠统治着波浪。你已经形成了自己的观点，不是吗？我的意思是，太糟糕了。是的，并不是说你同情德皇，我的意思是你们在很多方面都很相似，我想，而且……好吧，是的，我们不要继续这个类比了，但确实，在第一次世界大战之前，我认为有两件事在发生，一是焦虑，
one is the sort of the fear of the pompous strutting Kaiser and his dreadnoughts and Germany trying to get its own colonies and German manufacturers overtaking our own. But there also is this continuing fascination with Germany. So there's a guy called Haldane, Lord Haldane, who is the guy who builds up the British army before the First World War.
一是那种对傲慢、趾高气扬的德皇和他的无畏舰的恐惧，以及德国试图获得自己的殖民地，德国制造商超越我们自己的恐惧。但同时也有一种对德国持续的迷恋。所以有一个叫霍尔丹的人，霍尔丹勋爵，他是在第一次世界大战前建立英国军队的人。
And Haldane is a Germanophile, as many people were. And Haldane has spent lots of time in Germany. And actually, he then gets drummed out of office in the First World War because people say, oh, he's been spending all his summers in Germany. He's got all these German friends and he reads German books. And as a lot of intellectuals did in the Edwardian period. Absolutely. I mean, but even before that, you think of George Eliot and her crisis of faith
霍尔丹是一个亲德派，就像许多人一样。霍尔丹在德国花了很多时间。实际上，他在第一次世界大战中被赶出了办公室，因为人们说，哦，他所有的夏天都在德国度过。他有这么多德国朋友，他读德国书。正如爱德华时代的许多知识分子所做的那样。绝对是。我的意思是，但即使在那之前，想想乔治·艾略特和她的信仰危机，
because the sense that theologians in Germany are radically rewriting the basis for our understanding of Christian history. Absolutely massive impact. And that is across pretty much every academic discipline. It's Germany who's blazing the path. And I think that that does generate a kind of mixture of kind of fascination, inferiority, all of which obviously feeds into the swirl of opinion that helps push Britain into war against Germany in 1914. And then I think also slightly, I think slightly feeds some of the propaganda during the war. So obviously there's lots of the sort of stuff about the Germans have raped Belgium. They are, you know, Crucified Canadian soldiers. Crucifying people.
因为德国的神学家们正在从根本上重写我们理解基督教历史的基础。绝对是巨大的影响。这几乎涵盖了每一个学术领域。是德国在开辟道路。我认为这确实产生了一种迷恋和自卑的混合体，所有这些显然都助长了舆论的漩涡，帮助推动英国在1914年对德开战。然后我认为这也稍微助长了战争期间的一些宣传。所以显然有很多关于德国人强奸比利时人的报道。他们是，你知道，钉死加拿大士兵。钉死人。
They are raping nuns. They are bayoneting babies and stuff. A lot of which, you know, there's a grain of truth in that, as in the Germans do proceed with great sort of ferocity through Belgium. I thought that the revisionism of the revisionism was that actually there were terrible atrocities in Belgium.
他们强奸修女。他们用刺刀刺杀婴儿等等。其中很多，你知道，确实有一点真实成分，因为德国人确实在比利时以极大的凶猛程度推进。我以为修正主义的修正主义是说，实际上比利时确实发生了可怕的暴行。
I think there are atrocities, but I don't think they're quite the atrocities that are. So the Germans do shoot civilians. They do burn the Great Library in Louvain. They do behave very ferociously as an occupying force. I mean, actually, the comparison, Tom, is Cromwell in Ireland. It's exactly from the same motive. So the Germans, when they set off into Belgium, and the Belgians resist, the Germans are quite shocked that the Belgians are resisting. And their commanders basically say, you know, we have to do this incredibly
我认为有暴行，但我不认为它们完全是那种……所以德国人确实射杀了平民。他们确实烧毁了鲁汶大图书馆。作为占领军，他们的行为确实非常凶猛。我的意思是，实际上，汤姆，这个比较是克伦威尔在爱尔兰。动机完全一样。所以德国人出发进入比利时，而比利时人进行抵抗时，德国人对比利时人的抵抗感到非常震惊。他们的指挥官基本上说，你知道，我们必须非常
fiercely, and we will, you know, win the war, and we will impose order by fear. And we make them scared, otherwise they will shoot at us, and all this sort of thing. So it's done quite deliberately. But I don't think it's quite as savage as the sort of British newspaper coverage suggested. But I do think that what then happened, which is all these sort of people,
凶猛地这样做，我们才会赢得战争，我们将通过恐惧来强加秩序。我们要让他们害怕，否则他们会向我们开枪，诸如此类。所以这是非常蓄意地做的。但我不认为它像英国报纸报道的那样野蛮。但我确实认为后来发生的事情，也就是所有这些人，
you know, all these writers, the sort of Kiplings and, I don't know, HG Wells and Joseph Conrads or whatever, venturing into print and saying, oh, the Germans are just philistines and barbarians and blood drinking monsters. I think some of that is motivated by, oh, great. Now we don't have to worry about them being so clever anymore. Well, Kipling definitely, Kipling was massive. I mean, he hated Germans. Some of his short stories are terrible.
你知道，所有这些作家，像吉卜林，还有，我不知道，H.G.威尔斯和约瑟夫·康拉德之类的人，冒险发表文章说，哦，德国人只是庸俗的人、野蛮人和嗜血的怪物。我认为其中一些动机是，哦，太好了。现在我们不必再担心他们那么聪明了。好吧，吉卜林绝对是，吉卜林的影响力很大。我的意思是，他讨厌德国人。他的一些短篇小说很糟糕。
There's one with Mary Postgate, where there's a German aviator who is dying and she kind of leaves him to die in the garden. Yeah, really chilling stuff. And actually, it's often coming from people, I think, who 30 years earlier would have been all about Teutonic Brotherhood. And now they've just sort of turned that on its head. The Recessional, the famous poem that Kipling wrote at the Jubilee of Queen Victoria, saying, you know, lest we forget, lest we forget,
有一个关于玛丽·波斯特盖特的故事，里面有一个垂死的德国飞行员，她把他留在花园里等死。是的，非常令人不寒而栗。实际上，这通常来自那些我认为30年前会全力支持条顿兄弟情谊的人。现在他们只是把这一切颠倒过来了。吉卜林在维多利亚女王登基五十周年纪念时写的著名诗歌《退场》，说，你知道，免得我们忘记，免得我们忘记，
whether we end up one with Nineveh and Tyre. He notoriously talks about lesser breeds, and I think the lesser breeds in that are the Germans. Lesser breeds without the law? No, I don't think they're the Germans. I think they're the colonised peoples. I think there is debate. Is there?
免得我们最终与尼尼微和泰尔同归于尽。他臭名昭著地谈到了“劣等种族”，我认为其中的劣等种族是指德国人。“没有法律的劣等种族”？不，我不认为他们是德国人。我认为他们是被殖民的民族。我认为有争议。是吗？
I'm not au fait with Kipling's scholarship. I think there are people who think i'm not i'm not okay with kipling scholarship i think i think there are people who think that he may be referring to the germans there but anyway but but kipling there is voicing a kind of um a kind of horror really at the idea at germany as and and it's there that you're starting to get the idea that that because they they come to be called the Huns. Yes. Who obviously are actually Hungarians. But I mean, the idea that there is a kind of primal barbarism,
我不熟悉吉卜林的研究。我认为有人认为……我不熟悉吉卜林的研究，我想我想有人认为他可能是在指德国人，但无论如何，吉卜林在那里表达了一种……一种对德国作为……的恐惧，而且正是从那里你开始有了这种想法，因为他们开始被称为“匈奴人”。是的。他们显然实际上是匈牙利人。但我的意思是，那种存在一种原始野蛮的想法，
it's essentially the kind of the Roman idea. Yes. That beyond the Rhine. Well, people use the word barbarian. They use it all the time. All is, all is savagery and darkness.
这本质上是罗马人的那种想法。是的。莱茵河之外。好吧，人们使用“野蛮人”这个词。他们一直都在用。一切，一切都是野蛮和黑暗。
I mean, it's absolutely, it's kind of whole repudiation of that thing that had begun with, with Boniface. But then the interesting thing, Tom, is that that disappears so quickly so that by the 1920s it's all like you know um let's go and conclude some arms treaties with the germans um they're rebuilding there's a look there's a great sort of
我的意思是，这绝对是，这是一种对从博尼法斯开始的那种东西的彻底否定。但随后有趣的事情是，汤姆，它消失得如此之快，以至于到了1920年代，一切都像是，你知道，嗯，让我们去和德国人签订一些军备条约，他们正在重建，有一种……有一种伟大的……
don't let's be beast i mean the don't let's be beastly to the germans is a later phrase but there's a sense of that in the 1920s and 30s isn't there i mean that's what lies behind a lot of appeasement that the maybe we were a bit harsh on the germans they're not quite so bad they're trying to get back on their feet i'm not sure i i mean obviously that that um weimar berlin has a kind of hypnotic appeal for for british artists and writers and intellectuals so i think for us in england we we see weimar through the the the eyes of the people who did that. You know, Cabaret would be the kind of exemplification of that. Yeah, Christopher Isherwood type people.
“别对德国人太刻薄”，这是后来的说法，但在1920和30年代有一种这种感觉，不是吗？我的意思是，这就是许多绥靖政策背后的原因，也许我们对德国人太苛刻了，他们没那么坏，他们正在努力重新站起来。我不确定，我的意思是，显然魏玛柏林对英国艺术家、作家和知识分子有一种催眠般的吸引力，所以我认为对于我们英国人来说，我们是通过那些人的眼睛来看待魏玛的。你知道，《歌舞厅》就是那种典型的例子。是的，克里斯托弗·伊舍伍德那一类人。
But I think shadowing the whole time, there's the issue of what to do about Germany. And underlying that is the assumption that German power is inherently dangerous. And that's why britain maintain their alliance it's absolutely churchill's view and i think it's even there in in appeasement because the essentially it's kind of we might you know you it is maybe we push them too far maybe we we we exacted too much out of them but but i mean underlying appeasement is also the idea that you have to appease someone because if you don't they'll hit you well i mean i think i'm not i'm not sure about that but i think we should do a podcast just on appeasement and
但我认为一直笼罩在阴影中的是关于如何处理德国的问题。其根本假设是德国的力量本质上是危险的。这就是为什么英国维持他们的联盟，这绝对是丘吉尔的观点，我认为在绥靖政策中也存在这一点，因为本质上它是某种……我们可能，你知道，也许我们把他们逼得太紧了，也许我们从他们身上榨取了太多，但我的意思是，绥靖政策的根本也是一种想法，即你必须安抚某人，因为如果你不这样做，他们就会打你。好吧，我的意思是，我不确定，但我认为我们应该专门做一个关于绥靖政策的播客，而且
actually i want to tell you one thing we haven't talked about is what the germans think of britain because there's no doubt that lots of germans still after the first world war think of britain as their natural ally and their natural friend including hitler yeah so during the first world war there had been ton i mean a lot of germans had been absolutely appalled and horrified that britain had entered at all they had assumed that britain would not enter and then when britain um does they feel betrayed because they feel that their cousin has turned against them, siding with the French. Well, there's the Kaiser's great joke when George V changes the house of Saxe-Coburg
实际上我想告诉你一件事，我们还没谈过德国人怎么看英国，因为毫无疑问，第一次世界大战后，许多德国人仍然认为英国是他们天然的盟友和天然的朋友，包括希特勒。是的，所以在第一次世界大战期间，有很多德国人对英国参战感到非常震惊和恐惧。他们曾假设英国不会参战，然后当英国……真的参战时，他们感到被背叛了，因为他们觉得他们的表亲背叛了他们，站在了法国人一边。好吧，当乔治五世将萨克森-科堡王朝改为
to the house of Windsor. And the Kaiser wittily says, I'm off to see Shakespeare's play, The Merry Wives of Saxe-Coburg. To be fair, that's quite a good... It is a good joke. Yeah, the Kaiser did make one good joke. I think we can safely say that.
温莎王朝时，德皇开了一个大玩笑。德皇风趣地说：“我要去看莎士比亚的戏剧《萨克森-科堡的俏佳人》了。”公平地说，那确实是个不错的……那确实是个好笑话。是的，德皇确实讲了一个好笑话。我想我们可以肯定地说。
Wag. But you're right that for Hitler and the Nazis, England was not automatically an obvious enemy. And lots of senior Nazis did think, well, we can do a deal with the British. And, you know, sort of, I mean, Ian Kershaw said this, didn't he, when he was talking about how he got into
滑头。但你是对的，对于希特勒和纳粹来说，英国并不是自动成为明显的敌人。许多纳粹高层确实认为，好吧，我们可以和英国人达成协议。而且，你知道，我的意思是，伊恩·克肖说过这个，不是吗？当他谈到他是如何开始
doing the history of the Nazis, that a German guy said to him in the 1970s, we could have divided up the world between us. I think there was quite a lot of sentiment along those lines in the 1930s. Yeah. And Hitler, I mean, he admired British rule over India and kind of saw that as an exemplification of what he wanted. So, yes, there were aspects of Britain that even the Nazis admired. I mean, we were never going to not mention the war, so we might as well.
研究纳粹历史时，一个德国人在1970年代对他说，我们可以瓜分世界。我认为在1930年代有相当多的这种情绪。是的。而且希特勒，我的意思是，他钦佩英国对印度的统治，并将其视为他所追求的目标的典范。所以，是的，英国确实有即使是纳粹也钦佩的方面。我的意思是，我们永远不会不提到战争，所以我们不妨提一下。
I think what's interesting to me is that the propaganda, the British sense of Germany is, to my mind, actually not quite as intensely anti-German as it was in the first of all. It's more anti-Nazi. Yes. What is this? The Life and Times of Colonel Blimp? Yes. Which features an honourable Prussian figure who is seen as the best of Germany.
我认为对我来说有趣的是，宣传，英国对德国的感觉，在我看来，实际上并不像第一次世界大战时那样强烈地反德。它更多是反纳粹。是的。这是什么？《布林普上校的生与死》？是的。其中有一个光荣的普鲁士人物，被视为德国最好的一面。
And Churchill hated it, didn't he? He wanted it banned. He thought that it was kind of basically kind of pro-German propaganda. But even Churchill, on the other hand, Tom, said, for example, of Rommel. And I think Rommel is actually a really important figure in how British opinion kind of rehabilitated Germany after the war, because Rommel is the sort of the paradigm of the good German in British eyes. And even during the war, Churchill said of Rommel, he's a very great general and a noble antagonist or something like this.
丘吉尔讨厌它，不是吗？他想禁播它。他认为这基本上是一种亲德宣传。但另一方面，汤姆，即使是丘吉尔，也曾谈到过隆美尔。我认为隆美尔实际上是英国舆论在战后如何恢复德国形象的一个非常重要的人物，因为隆美尔在英国人眼中是“好德国人”的典范。即使在战争期间，丘吉尔也曾评价隆美尔说，他是一位伟大的将军，一位高尚的对手之类的。
So, you know, there was always this sense, which I don't think really existed in the First World War, that there was another Germany, that the Nazis had suppressed, as it were, the real Germany. And there was another Germany that was noble and, you know, upstanding and virtuous and a sort of decent enemy, and that that had somehow been lost. Which is then terribly important when the war is over, and Britain is one
所以，你知道，一直有这种感觉，我不认为这在第一次世界大战中真正存在，即存在另一个德国，纳粹压制了真正的德国。还有另一个德国，它是高尚的、正直的、有德行的，是一个体面的敌人，而那种东西不知何故丢失了。这在战争结束后变得非常重要，当时英国是
of the four occupying powers, and obviously plays a crucial role in deciding what will happen to Germany after the war. And actually, British policy after the war seems to me an incredible bright spot in Anglo-German relations. Well, it's a British officer who rebuilds Volkswagen, for example. Yes, yeah, yeah. And Britain plays a kind of crucial role in re-establishing German democracy and re-establishing German industry and actually kind of learning from problems that Britain has and ensuring that
四个占领国之一，显然在决定战后德国命运方面发挥了关键作用。实际上，战后英国的政策在我看来是英德关系中一个令人难以置信的亮点。好吧，例如，是一位英国军官重建了大众汽车。是的，是的。英国在重建德国民主和德国工业方面发挥了关键作用，实际上是从英国遇到的问题中吸取教训，并确保
Germany doesn't have them. Yeah, I think that's true. I mean, don't forget there were American policymakers, you said. The answer to this after two world wars is to break up Germany forever, to break it up, destroy its industry and just turn it into this sort of... Kind of forest. Yeah, into basically Switzerland, into lots of little Switzerland's so that it can never again menace europe and and i think one reason for not doing that was by this point fear of germany had been overtaken by fear of russia and having a strong germany was seen as an important bulwark against the soviet union
德国不会遇到这些问题。是的，我认为那是真的。我的意思是，别忘了还有美国决策者，你说过。两次世界大战后的答案是永远分裂德国，分裂它，摧毁它的工业，把它变成这种……某种森林。是的，基本上变成瑞士，变成许多小瑞士，这样它就永远不能再威胁欧洲了。我认为不这样做的一个原因是，到那时，对德国的恐惧已经被对俄罗斯的恐惧所取代，拥有一个强大的德国被视为对抗苏联的重要堡垒。
yeah so so obviously um going into um 50s 60s 70s there are so many ambivalences there but i guess you are as well qualified to trace as anyone because you've written about them. Oh, you're very kind, Tom. That's nice. I think, yes, I think the most interesting,
是的，所以显然……进入50、60、70年代，那里有太多的矛盾，但我猜你和任何人一样有资格去追溯它们，因为你写过关于它们的内容。哦，你太客气了，汤姆。那很好。我想，是的，我认为最有趣的，
I mean, obviously, there are memories of the war. There are people who went by German cars. And you see that reflected in Dad's Army and obviously most famously in Fawlty Towers that don't mention the war. But Fawlty Towers, the joke is against Basil Fawlty. Well, that's exactly the thing.
我的意思是，显然，有关于战争的记忆。有人开德国车。你在《老爸上战场》中看到了这一点，显然最著名的是在《弗尔蒂旅馆》中，不要提到战争。但《弗尔蒂旅馆》的笑话是针对巴兹尔·弗尔蒂的。好吧，那正是重点。
It's not against the Germans, is it? So Basil, there are lots of people like Basil, but you're right. The Germans are progressive, decent, kindly people who come to stay at the hotel and are shocked by Basil's conduct. And certainly by the 70s, I think West Germany in British eyes was the exemplar of sort of European modernity. So there are tons of articles in the British newspapers in the sort of mid-70s saying German labour relations, German factories, German education system, we should learn from them, Germany is the perfect
它不是针对德国人的，对吧？所以巴兹尔，有很多像巴兹尔这样的人，但你是对的。德国人是进步、体面、友善的人，他们来酒店住宿，却被巴兹尔的行为震惊了。当然到了70年代，我认为在英国人眼中，西德是欧洲现代性的典范。所以70年代中期英国报纸上有大量的文章说德国的劳资关系、德国的工厂、德国的教育体系，我们应该向他们学习，德国是完美的
kind of modern country. You know, Helmut Schmidt, the social democratic leader of Germany in the 1970s, is brought over to address the Labour Party conference to basically say, you know, we support you in your attempts to stop so many strikes and inflation and so on. And there is this absolute sense, you know, Germany is the future and we should be more like Germany. And I think that we still have that. I mean, I think that's still quite an important strain within British public opinion. Yes, I think certainly in what you would call
现代国家。你知道，1970年代德国社会民主党领袖赫尔穆特·施密特被请来在工党大会上发表演讲，基本上是说，你知道，我们支持你们努力阻止那么多的罢工和通货膨胀等等。有一种绝对的感觉，你知道，德国就是未来，我们应该更像德国。我认为我们仍然有那种感觉。我的意思是，我认为这在英国舆论中仍然是一个相当重要的倾向。是的，我想肯定是在你所说的
a slightly progressive opinion. But I think even the two World Wars and one World Cup, it's slightly embarrassing because, you know, I mean, Germans have won four times. Yeah, they've won lots of World Cups. And for us, you know, this fixture is massive. But for them it's actually not. For them it isn't.
稍微进步的舆论中。但我认为即使是两次世界大战和一次世界杯，也稍微有点尴尬，因为，你知道，我的意思是，德国人赢了四次。是的，他们赢了很多次世界杯。对我们来说，你知道，这场比赛非常重要。但对他们来说实际上并不是。对他们来说不是。
We're in a way much more obsessed by German success than, I mean, we barely intrude on them. I think you're absolutely right. Maybe we don't. I don't know. Iude on them. I think you're absolutely right. Maybe we don't. I don't know. I don't know. Maybe that's not entirely true. But I think that we are more obsessed by Germany as an opponent than the Germans are by us.
我们在某种程度上比他们更痴迷于德国的成功，我的意思是，我们几乎不打扰他们。我想你是绝对正确的。也许我们没有。我不知道。我不知道。也许那不完全是真的。但我认为我们作为对手对德国的痴迷程度要高于德国人对我们的痴迷程度。
I think that's right. In footballing terms. I also think, and also I think in political terms, actually, and I think the key moment is not going out to the Germans on penalties in Euro 96. It's going out to the Germans on penalties in 1990. And it's not just that. I don't mean that sort of facetiously just as a footballing point but obviously it's at that point the german unification is on the agenda and mrs thatcher who had been a great champion of west germany actually and had actually in the late 70s early 80s had explicitly said west germ is a model for britain to follow she completely changes her tune at the
我认为那是对的。在足球方面。我也认为，而且我认为在政治方面也是如此，实际上，我认为关键时刻不是在96年欧洲杯上点球输给德国人。而是在1990年点球输给德国人。而且不仅仅是那样。我不是轻浮地把它仅仅作为一个足球观点，但显然在那个时候，德国统一提上了议程，撒切尔夫人，她曾是西德的伟大拥护者，实际上在70年代末80年代初曾明确表示西德是英国效仿的榜样，她在
end of the 80s early 90s because she is the great opponent of german unification because she basically recognizes i mean not not she's not wrong she recognizes that united germany will be the powerhouse of europe and she doesn't like it and she tries to stop it and she fails and chance the coal invites her over doesn't he for yes. To his hometown and treats her to traditional local delicacies. It's actually more moving than that. I mean, Chancellor Cole, who is, I mean, in Britain is seen as a comic figure, but elsewhere I think is seen as a genuinely sort of... Well, literally a giant.
80年代末90年代初完全改变了调子，因为她是德国统一的伟大反对者，因为她基本上认识到——我的意思是，她并没有错——她认识到统一的德国将成为欧洲的强国，她不喜欢它，她试图阻止它，但她失败了。科尔总理邀请她过去，不是吗？是的。去他的家乡，并用传统的当地美食款待她。实际上比那更感人。我的意思是，科尔总理，在英国被视为一个滑稽人物，但在其他地方我认为他被视为一个真正……好吧，字面上的巨人。
Literally a giant, exactly. He has this sort of buried romantic side and he wants to, he takes her around and he sort of shows her the sights and he wants to show her the soul of Germany and how much Germany has suffered and how it has rebuilt and this sort of, this vision that he has. And all she can say when she gets back is, oh my God, that man is so German.
字面上的巨人，没错。他有一种深藏的浪漫一面，他带着她四处走动，向她展示景点，他想向她展示德国的灵魂，以及德国遭受了多少苦难，它是如何重建的，这种愿景。而她回来后所能说的只是：“天哪，那个人太德国了。”
I know, I know, I know. Yeah. I mean, the thing is there, Tom, she's kind of speaking for the nation, isn't she? I mean, that's what a lot of British people think. Well, and she had to sack, is it Nicholas Ridley, who was kind of a very close political ally. He was employment secretary or something. And he wrote an article in The Spectator saying that the common market, whatever it was then.
我知道，我知道，我知道。是的。我的意思是，汤姆，她在那里基本上是在为国家代言，不是吗？我的意思是，这就是许多英国人的想法。好吧，她不得不解雇尼古拉斯·里德利，他是她非常亲密的政治盟友。他是就业大臣还是什么的。他在《旁观者》杂志上写了一篇文章，说共同市场，无论当时叫什么。
It's a German plot. It's a German racket. A German racket. They gave it to Europe. racket german racket that's a very good and um i guess i mean i guess that that was that was kind of a motivating factor in the brexit campaign perhaps i mean i think that's still kind of slight well i think once germany and france i mean so much of this in this discussion france has been there and france is the antagonist. And a shared suspicion of France has allowed Germans and Britons to unite. Once France and Germany, as it were, buried the hatchet in a massive way in the sort of 50s and 60s and became the twin pillars of the European Union, then suddenly Britain was on the outside.
这是一个德国阴谋。这是一个德国骗局。德国骗局。他们把它给了欧洲。骗局，德国骗局，那是一个非常好的……而且，嗯，我猜，我猜那可能是英国脱欧运动的一个推动因素，我的意思是，我认为那仍然有点……好吧，我认为一旦德国和法国……我的意思是，在这个讨论中，法国一直都在那里，法国是对手。而对法国的共同怀疑使德国人和英国人团结在一起。一旦法国和德国在50和60年代以一种巨大的方式埋葬了斧头，成为欧盟的双柱，那么英国突然就成了局外人。
And I think that obviously played a huge part in the Brexit campaign, the sense that there's a Franco-German alliance, which had never really existed before. But also that the Franco-German alliance had been there from the beginning, and so therefore Britain was always having to adjust to Franco-German norms. Yes. And the cost of doing that proved too too high with yeah i mean i think
我认为这显然在脱欧运动中发挥了巨大作用，那种认为存在一个法德联盟的感觉，这在以前从未真正存在过。但也因为法德联盟从一开始就在那里，所以英国总是不得不适应法德规范。是的。而这样做的代价被证明太高了……是的，我的意思是，我认为
we know absolutely i think that's um but but having said all that i think i mean i i think that um for all the talk of um you know anglo-german hostility that uh this the football match will will generate um you know the very fact it's inspired us to do this podcast. I do think that actually, certainly in England, there is a huge admiration for Germany. That's true. I think that's something that, you know, we saw through the 90s, and I don't think anything has happened since then to change it.
我们绝对知道，我认为那是……但话虽如此，我的意思是，我认为……尽管有关于英德敌对的讨论，但这场足球比赛将激发我们做这个播客。我确实认为，实际上，当然在英国，对德国有巨大的钦佩。那是真的。我认为那是我们通过90年代看到的东西，我不认为从那时起发生了什么改变它的事情。
I think there's a sort of respect for Germany, isn't there? There's a deep respect for germany for the way they've they've they've dealt with the traumas of the 20th century um for lots of things working i mean the one they don't get everything right they've got this dreadful airport in berlin which is the which they've been building for about the last three centuries and i think it's only well that's it but that's a kind of that's an entertaining throwback to to the germany of the 1820s. Yes, I guess so. Sort of shambolic and fragmented. Yes.
我认为有一种对德国的尊重，不是吗？对德国有一种深深的尊重，因为他们处理20世纪创伤的方式，因为很多事情……我的意思是，他们并没有把所有事情都做对，他们在柏林有一个糟糕的机场，他们已经建了大约三个世纪了，我想它只是……好吧，那是，但那是一种对1820年代德国的娱乐性回顾。是的，我想是这样。有点混乱和支离破碎。是的。
But you're right. I think, speaking purely for myself, I think Germany is an amazing country. I love German culture. And I think to go to a country that works as well is tremendous. And as much as the Germans beat themselves up, or we like to beat up the Germans, I think they're I'm a great Teutonic brotherhood man I mean I'm pure Victorian Anglo-Saxon fraternity and all that I really go in for that well I think I think I mean I do think another thing that that has um
但你是对的。我想，纯粹代表我自己，我认为德国是一个了不起的国家。我热爱德国文化。而且我认为去一个运作得如此良好的国家是极好的。尽管德国人喜欢自我批评，或者我们喜欢批评德国人，但我认为他们是……我是一个伟大的条顿兄弟情谊的人，我的意思是，我是纯粹的维多利亚时代盎格鲁-撒克逊兄弟会那一套，我真的很喜欢那个。好吧，我想，我的意思是，我确实认为另一件……
Germany is inherited from you know the 18 early 19th century is this kind of slight sense of moral seriousness which yes which we tend to find risible. Yeah, that's true. That is very true. We're kind of... They mean what they say. We can't cope with... They say what they mean.
德国从19世纪初继承下来的东西是这种轻微的道德严肃感，是的，我们往往觉得这很可笑。是的，那是真的。那是非常真实的。我们有点……他们言出必行。我们无法应对……他们言行一致。
They do. They do. And I think it's impossible not to admire that from our island as we titter and giggle our way into the sea. We have some... My wife had a German student, and she stayed in touch with her, and she and her husband her husband they're both teachers they often come to visit us and um he uh the last time they came to visit us at the end of the evening i said coffee and he said i know
他们确实如此。他们确实如此。而且我认为从我们的岛屿上，当我们咯咯笑着走向大海时，不可能不钦佩这一点。我们有一些……我妻子的一个德国学生，她和她保持着联系，她和她的丈夫，他们都是老师，他们经常来看望我们，嗯，他……上次他们来看望我们时，在晚上结束时，我说咖啡，他说：“我知道
you all appreciate plain speaking here in england i would like a bottle of red wine which i thought was um admirably yeah very teutonic behavior but but uh dominic we we are here descending into the worst kinds of national stereotyping and i think before we disgrace ourselves yeah any further we should uh we should blow the whistle on this um this romp through the centuries and and you are you again they won't be watching the big match because you've got to go to your sons sports day pirates vs mermaids
你们在英国都欣赏直言不讳，我想要一瓶红酒。”我觉得那是……令人钦佩的，是的，非常条顿的行为。但，多米尼克，我们在这里陷入了最糟糕的民族刻板印象，我认为在我们让自己蒙羞之前，是的，任何进一步的，我们应该……我们应该对这次跨越世纪的漫游吹哨停止。而且你，你又……他们不会看那场大战，因为你得去参加你儿子的运动会，海盗对美人鱼。
I'm absolutely pumped so what I'm going to do is I'm going to record the game not talk to any parents yeah exactly and try to watch it afterwards I'm very excited about it I'm so looking forward to phoning you up, texting you.
我绝对兴奋极了，所以我打算做的是，我打算录下比赛，不和任何家长说话，是的，完全正确，并尝试事后观看。我对此非常兴奋。我非常期待给你打电话，给你发短信。
Do not. I do not. If anyone out there would like to tweet Dominic or text him the result, much merriment will follow. Anyway, Dominic, thanks ever so much. I hope you managed not to find out the result and to watch it live, as it were. Thanks very much for listening. Enjoy the football if you're watching the football. We will be back soon with yet more.
不要。我不要。如果外面有任何人想给多米尼克发推特或发短信告诉他结果，将会引发很多欢乐。总之，多米尼克，非常感谢。我希望你设法没有提前知道结果，并能现场观看比赛。非常感谢收听。如果你在看足球，祝你享受足球。我们很快会带着更多内容回来。
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Auf Wiedersehen. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余味》。如需额外剧集、抢先体验、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。那是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。